okay I am back then that looks okay the
video looks okay hopefully the audio is
okay
I have a very strange setup right now
I'm outside I'm actually on the ground
and my laptop and my microphone are
currently like on a small like pool
table a small portable pool table so
what I want to do is play people if you
want to challenge me
let me open the checks oh wow people are
here I took five mins on my name I took
five mins on my name is like always the
first person here thanks for watching
hello I'm singer 24 I know I haven't
been streaming recently at least the
last few days and I got messages all the
time from people who like asked me where
I am
shoutout to sub ham let me respond to
slug him yes I'm streaming right now
okay so yeah if if people are watching
and you want to play me send me a
challenge on Li Ches maybe the easiest
way to do that is to type in and reach
us in the chat and then you can send me
a challenge Wow the first sub J s il JCS
il-86 just subscribed and by the way I
don't think I've publicly announced this
yet but I became a twitch partner about
four days ago five days ago we have our
first challenger let's accept this so
any subscribers now get access to the
Fabiano emotes which I'm pretty proud of
so we have the first game pony for 9 f3
let's see if we'll transpose into some
kind of like pansy on ed5 I think I can
wait do I take or do I play d5 I'll take
and then we'll play some kind of
Scandinavian Queen d8 so he's inspired
by John Bartholomew
okay I'll play D for ya so JC s now has
the Fabiano emotes I do want to ask the
viewers if you if you have like an email
request if there's a particular player
or symbol or just anything that you want
me to make let me know I'm in the
process of going through like old photos
and trying to see what could potentially
work for an emotes am i threatening some
I think I'm threatening Bishop take f7
and Knight g5 here maybe he'll fall for
it I assume this person's watching I
don't know if he's disguised as someone
in the chat also let me know is the
audio okay because I'm outside there's
background noise there's traffic it was
people talking at my friend's apartment
in Hollywood right now playing Bishop
III safe and solid if he takes on after
he I'll take back with queen and then if
he takes on d4 I win d7 in the meantime
I just might want to play h3 g4
grapefruit or typhoon both I mean
yesterday I had I had a lot of Thai food
and at least one or two grapefruits so
it was a good a good mix of things a
little Plotkin emotes that's actually a
really good suggestion but what what
would the emote be would they be his
face because I don't think his face is
too recognizable maybe we would just say
like little Plotkin and really like tiny
letters I guess if it's an emo that has
to be timing after brains from some
ideas for that well on Fuji is asking
what you think about the current u.s.
championship standings I will admit that
I have no idea what the results were
today and I should probably make an
effort to check on online to see what
happens
I was watching yesterday for a little
bit I saw the Fabiano finish and that
was uh that was pretty sad for him and I
did look earlier today I know he was
playing Shanklin and Shanklin had a good
position
but if anyone has a news if Shanklin one
or Fabiano held a draw I would be
interested to know box is asking who is
your favorite historical nonliving chess
player so my favorite dead chess player
she haven't thought about that you know
I have a lot of favorite living chess
players
okay let's destroy his pawn structure
can Castle kingside
favorite non living chess player mmm
I mean Karpov is still alive Korchnoi
trying to think of someone who I like
Mets and that inspired me okay I have a
name he passed away only a few years ago
I've actually played him I think once in
a tournament his name was Danny Mayer's
he's not like known for chess but he's
it was like 85 or 90 years old and still
playing like tournaments all over the
country in the US and he has a really
interesting life story
he lived in Idaho but he worked on like
the nuclear bomb like in the early days
of like he had a really really
interesting life I would recommend
googling his name and the one year I
played him was the tournament in
Foxwoods in 2007 and it was a tournament
that I became an expert where I broke
two thousand and my game against him he
played the Smith Morra and there were
about maybe four or five moments during
the game where he just fell asleep but
he just took a short nap so I think at
that time he was like in his mid 80s and
he used like a magnifying glass to to
take notation it was pretty cool any
memories of whoa Joe uh actually I met
whoa Joe only once and he can't he
visited Chicago and he gave a Simon and
he absolutely crushed me I was probably
like 1,500 at the time
but I remember him like being a pretty
nice guy kind of wish I knew him more
because I know he was pretty there's a
pretty iconic chess figure like back
during the early days of us chess JCS is
saying I want to troll korilla Oh with a
little [ __ ] emo okay yeah hello to
Jay Jay I for one to Joe I do have a
favor to ask everyone who's watching I'm
gonna just type in a command in the chat
I'm currently behind in a Twitter poll
and I need as many votes as possible I'm
losing to hammer and all I need I need
like 50 or 60 more votes so if everyone
is watching the stream can votes there
is money on the line and it would be
awesome if I can stage a comeback in in
the two hours that are left in the poll
let's focus on this game though the
positions kind of heating up he wants to
trade queens but I don't think whites
should trade queens here because this
queen is maybe a target and is a nice
kind of other play I'm just gonna play
Queen on Queen g3 ones into Bishop d6
let's play Queen f3 and someday I want
to play 93 95 and this is the c6 quad
it's just a long-term weakness like you
can never push it it's already attacked
once by the Queen 993 here maybe I'll
play rook e1 95 and betrayal any five my
rook comes to e5 and then gets to c5 I
just want to eventually like win all
those pawns
thank you messy Marvin promoting really
appreciate that 85 is he's stacking upon
it's not a free pawn B take a 595
positional sacrifice what do I do
I mean pawns upon B take a 595 knight c5
and then I'm threatening 97 and I can
play a six okay let's do it
95 is a really nice multi-purpose move
because I defend the c3 pawn with the
Queen I'm threatening 97 with the triple
fork and I'm planning a six
oh maybe he's debating whether or not to
take on a four I forgot that pawns kind
of hanging but then his Knights kind of
out of play okay he takes weird position
because his Queen side down to the night
the night has very few moves he might
want to take on c3 decks very spicy play
eight six
she queen g1 maybe traps tonight no
Queen d1 things by night five hundred
bits from BG thank you so much but any
bits given to me at this moment will
only distract me the play rook F c1 it's
a safe move I'm just supporting c3
elastic hold is back yeah elastic hold I
responded to your message on stream
that's how I started the stream c5 he's
being ambitious but I can play queen c6
and this night oh my but Knight is
hanging I forgot my knight was hanging
I'll have to flag him because then when
he takes my knight he takes my bishop
that's such a bad move I like my
position too okay I'll take with Queen
hey good thing this is a casual game
wait a minute this is bad that's what
happens when I get distracted from the
chat
have to blame that on on bg7 for being
the bits leader weight is bg7 my
opponents so that would be a really
interesting strategy to just like throw
bits in the time scramble take take the
problem is that if I take on d4 he takes
in my rook and f2 pawn or attacks you
know I can't take I have to play c4 but
then d3 okay I'll go for the sign for d1
or I have a seven intermediate let's
play rugby one first tactical wizard is
here it's been a while okay I'm gonna
keep attacking this Queen keep attacking
his Queen five bits says Nathan F don't
flag let's play Queen here I just have
to survive for like 20 seconds he keeps
taking time work out for one safe move
Bishop take F - that hurts but okay he's
not gonna make me in ten seconds I feel
pretty comfortable now I mean he has a
completely winning position but maybe I
can made him five seven eight am I gonna
made him work h4 I'm threatened mates in
one oh he has Bishop c7 or did he I
don't know King h1 hey I'm winning
and he's flagging I'm taking oh my god
she almost had rook e1 there that
wouldn't be make his queen g1 but that
was a really messy finish thank you guys
for throwing bits shout out Nathan F for
15 bits have I played Lila zero I try
challenging Lila zero a few days ago but
it doesn't allow title players to
challenge it was only only after the
Andrew Tang match
but the and rooting match was today so I
believe I could play Leela's ero if I
wanted to I'm gonna play some ham
because of ham was like dying for me to
stream and will reward him or her with
the game I think is this person from st.
Louis I think we've met in person and
I'll be going to st. Louis in two days
starting my drive tomorrow and then
arriving on Tuesday so if you're in st.
Louis and you're visiting US
Championships or you just live in st.
Louis let me know happy to meet in
person we're gonna play this line where
black has wasted at tempo playing east
six and ninety five but it's not it's
not that bad because White's setup is
not too desirable with a pawn on e4 and
Bishop on g2 oh wow thanks F cats for
hosting I feel like I know who's f cat
is another streamer on the chess board
but who is it
I can picture her face why I can't I
can't remember her name
am i doing a simultaneity terpil how
about that my Twitter poll is very very
close the poll ends in about an hour and
a half I'm currently behind to John Luke
hammer so if you want to vote for me go
on Twitter and vote for me it's a
streamer poll so I would be very happy
to to defeat hammer than any sort of
streamer poll Bishop g4 okay I'll let me
advertise the thing again I don't like
to advertise too much but I'm I'm in
desperate need of votes 94 is coming and
he's gonna have to move back to d1 life
is good oh he has my t5 though
and then it's almost like complete
symmetry but queen bee 695 Queen take b2
90 got six planting Essex that looks
reasonable
he's rugby one though in the end I'm
calculating some very deep I and take on
me to take on a two he takes on b7o
chess is difficult I mean I put my
Bishop on c5 this is a simpler approach
so the bishop comes to c5 then both my
bishop and my knight are happy
his Knight could be happy but his bishop
will never be happy
and then there's constant pressure to f2
okay Brooke c1 is kind of annoying
maybe I'll play Queen d6 discouraging
before and at some point I want to like
put the rooks in the center maybe play
f5 even open that file enabling more
pressure on it against f2 a5 is maybe
the type of move I should have
calculated but here I'm just playing it
on intuition and there's lots of x-ray
vision against the pawn against the King
my Knights doing a good job at
restricting his Queen let's just take or
do I want to take I don't want to make
this bishop happy PDF for a4 or take
take let's not change the position too
much I'm gonna play a six I create a
safety Square for my bishop in case he
plays before and I'm also threatening b5
and if I play b5 then he has to retreat
this Queen most likely to d1 tactical
wizard is making a Twitter account just
to vote for me I'm so honored I've been
in to Twitter polls this year so far
they were all part of like chess comm
stuff
the first one was for approach s League
and I I got more votes than Carl Carlson
and caravana which is really exciting
Brooksie satin is aggressive move what
is he threatening anything I don't think
so
do this hammer is at 160 I'm at 100 so I
need 60 more votes okay
that's doable I think maybe yes we'll
find out there's only like an hour left
hammer mishandled classified emails yeah
that sounds like hammer
that's whoa let's not hang a bishop
again I'm getting distracted this Queen
might want to come in to my house maybe
work at the c8 it's not the most
desirable move but I just want to trade
off his most active piece more bits from
Nathan being distracted I mean it's
working but sometimes if you can play
chess in very distracting settings then
it's just a good like it's a good skill
set to have especially in tournaments
when there's like noises or like babies
in the room that they're crying and
you're just like in the zone so let's
try and get in the zone here as Knights
annoying the positions about to explode
let's take pawns my Knights still
defended that was an interesting move
and the play rook c8 whoa let's take the
pawn in a - oh wait he's fighting bishop
d5 so let's not longer a queen king h7
this positions exploding
uh this pond scary and sking is
relatively safe
now this pond might be weak my gosh
Nathan with a bit stop distracting me
take the pawn I guess ok sub ham is
nervous I can see the hesitation he just
hung to pieces with one move now I can
probably start flagging him ok three
seconds plenty of time Hey
also known as elastic hold I'm not gonna
rematch because I have pending
challenges maybe we'll play later though
Annius is asking just playing on me
chess affect your feed a rating no it
does not
feeder rating is only affected in feed
eight tournaments and it requires a feed
a arbiter so sometimes feed a
tournaments our heart defines but yeah
playing on the HS only affects truly
chess ratings as far as I know let's
play X storm X 159 which I've had
trouble against we actually have an
equal score so let me try to get on a
plus score I feel like the last two
games we played I've accidentally played
this myth Mora so let's play some more
mainstream opening there should be five
check why not it's a fun line and c40
book did something very similar to
Wesley so a few days ago in the
tournament and they had some really
really interesting position or potential
potentially interesting position
resulting from this line I take e for is
a really cool move please play it so I
can show my preparation you can still
play it you win a pawn it's a center
pawn
mmm I think he's considering taking it
okay he's being boring g6 plate rookie
one after this game I do want to show
the viewers what happens after a night a
key for it because there's some really
really cool lines but for now we're
gonna just develop pieces and play
decent chess
do you like the accelerated dragon the
accelerated dragon is my like secret
back pocket opening it's it's what I
like to play if I want to surprise my
opponent as whack 95% of the time
against before I'll play time on of
Sicilian which is just it's a reliable
opening for me but excited dragon can be
dangerous in certain lines Nathan F is
asking where I'm at
where where am i I'm currently in
Hollywood I'm at a friend's apartment
really nice location really nice
apartment I'm flying back to Chicago
tonight
and I have some time to kill right now I
play knight c6 and maybe go for the
trade if he wants to take and I'll get
the bishop hair more bits o bits from
sub ham or bits from elastic hold same
person this should be seven I think wins
upon a classic rook pawn fork oh except
I lost c4 but I win a six
okay and the goal with this game is just
to win and an improve on my sub optimal
score max 459 is a player that I always
underestimates like he's tricky but in
this game oh this game has increments so
I can't I can't flag him too easily the
play Bishop e3 and complete developments
oh he wants to take the bishop I think
the goal is to hang on to the bishop
care because bishops are just so
effective especially in like pawn
structures like this where there's
action on both sides and especially if I
can get some past past Queen side pawn
the Bishop's can support that night c4
he's being annoying maybe 984 attack the
rook someday I want to play b3 maybe
I'll play b3 next move if it works
tactically not entirely sure
b3 Knight takes e4 could be a problem
wait b3 Knight a key for this should
take a four let's do it it splits to use
intuition
I think Knight a key for Bishop takes c4
and then I attack his Knight by rotating
this but I think it's okay Nathan is
asking and like playing at Chicago open
oh you'll be there I I probably am not
playing to be honest but I might play
some side events and I'll definitely
stop by at least on one or two days so
yeah it's a it's a great tournament it
attracts a lot of players but it's a lot
of games and it's only a 5 day it's only
5 days to play 9 rounds so it's pretty
tiring I mean I might make the decision
to play last minute but I would have to
I would have to be well-prepared like
I'm not gonna just play for the sake of
playing this positions getting tricky
my pawn is hanging my rook is vulnerable
I mean is a Ponting problem is if I take
on a for you takes on e4 and then rook
be one Knight c3 some this should be two
maybe there should be to neutralize the
diagonal he could win the pawn but then
we're trading a pawn for a pawn
I guess Senate sequel material Oh Queen
d4e is nine of six so I'll take the a
pawn I mean the pawn structure is better
for black but I have the bishop against
the night and this past a pawn could be
dangerous
sometime in the near future except if he
trades it off she's about to do okay at
least I have the time advantage and I
have the only passed pawn on the board
but how do I make use of it a for Queen
eight five maybe Queen B - at some
points I have to figure out the plan
here
people are distracting in the chats
let's play Queen B -
an idea is to play Queen beef five the
Barons into rook c5 chess is so
difficult it's why Queen before I just
wanted to stop him from playing queen 85
and now I want to push my con it's kind
of slow but hopefully he'll think more
okay let's play a four the problem is
he's both these pawns are potentially
weak like they're both isolated the good
thing for me is that this pawn is kind
of backwards he's threatening to take on
c4 I have to play rook c1 you'll play
Brook II for a bit more active maybe I
can like surprise checkmate him can't
really draw arrows but do something like
this and then this how do I make that
happen
eight-five loses a pawn wait does if I
lose upon probably loses upon we need
one is interesting okay I'm gonna play
Queen e1 I want him to move the pawn if
he moves upon them it weakens a d6 fun
and if he moves upon I'll probably come
back to some square like c3 also I'm
just trying to make him think Queen c3
sure Nathan F thanks for the vote and
thanks for the bits I'm gonna play rook
e1
I really want him to move this fawn or
just give me the pawn for free now King
f8 runs into Queen h8 maids so he moves
upon I'm gonna move back open t5 is
coming uh defy ok his two threats we're
both running well on time
I think this defends everything yeah
this is really tricky and the play rook
h4 I still want the surprise checkmate
idea he's about to flag oh he had 2
seconds left uh Queen and b7 why not
please flag please flag yes he Flags I
don't feel good about winning that but I
feel relieved that I didn't lose that
shoutout to z nation chess Hansie nation
chess I know it looks bad that I said
I'm busy today and I had to like not
give a lesson but this Twitter poll is
the most important thing going on and I
need all the votes that I can get wait
what's the serious question what kind of
what kind of materials is presented in
divorce fees analytical manual I have no
idea
I'm sure Amazon could answer that if you
don't know how to use Amazon you can go
to looks wrong tab let me go to a new
tab amazon.com give wretzky analytical
manual and then you can read the reviews
I'm sure he gives some overview to read
more
oh the read more button oh the read more
button is kind of working I don't know
maybe it doesn't give a great overview
but maybe other people in the chat can
can assist with that I'm sure out of
everyone watching is it this one person
who asked that book that one person
wants to answer that question please go
ahead and do so I took 5 mins is asking
how much does it cost to travel to
tournaments I will say there is a there
is a skill in being able to travel on a
budget like usually the costs of travel
are transportation accommodation and
food and there's ways to minimize all of
those costs sometimes you have to be
creative like sometimes you want to look
for train rides over flights or bus
rides there are times where you can get
really cheap flights to give you travel
on weekdays or do what I'm doing and
take like an overnight flights you can
significantly reduce the cost especially
if you're flexible with days to but
that's a whole other area that that's
not it's not delve into too much I would
never question you like that oh thank
you
see nation for understanding have I
checked out Sam Jenkins book I saw Sam
Franklin's lecture in st. Louis chess
club and I really enjoyed the lecture
like he's a really good teacher and I
like for myself I learned a lot from
from his lecture or something some
simple concepts like pawns can't move
backwards but his material was really
instructive and like he did a really
good job at like showing all the key
variations but he talks really fast so
if you're if you're maybe an amateur
player and you listen to his lecture
maybe you have to listen to it at like
half the speed half the speed yeah half
the speed not twice the speed just to
like
absorb all the lines because he he
rattles out variations very very quickly
I was gonna accept another challenge but
I remember that I wanted to show some
moment in the opening they were actually
discussing I think they were discussing
this exact position in the US
Championship commentary and Maryse was
giving some some interesting lines but
rumor ISA was using the engine and I was
watching and I was very upset that he
didn't mention like one of the the key
lines for whites or one of the key moves
for whites and that was that was about
the jariabek Wesley game so of course
all the fun happens after 94 might take
me for like can play rookie one neither
6d for tape take and now I mean White's
time upon it looks like black can
develop normally with g6 Bishop g7 and
castling but White has a really really
really cool move after g6 and it's the
type of move that you probably won't be
able to find unless you're using stock
fish so stock dishes recommendation here
is 96 it's a pretty it's pretty what's
the right word I was about to say
disgusting it's a pretty epic move idea
of being that there's so many pins in
the position the e pawn is pinned so
it's not really defending either the d6
pawn or the Knights and also in many
cases the 997 is pinned so one of the
nice lines here is that after pawn takes
c6 Bishop takes c6
rook e8 there's amazing Queen take d6
and because the Knights pinned and the
pawn is pinned White's threatening both
Queen take f6 and Queen take the eights
it's just such a cool position I know
this this idea happens and some other
similar lines but it's nice opening
preparation and it starts from the c-4
line which thinks c4 is a pretty rare
move if we look at the stats
yeah c4 is one two three four five
it's a six most popular move so not
played too often maybe there's been
games that have gone down this line
castle oh these are games Omni chess so
in tournaments let's go to the turn the
database masters database
ah there's been two games after Knight
f6 Castle oh one of the games is mine I
forgot about that
I played roofing Leaney in this line
that was awful time like I uh that was a
the time where I prepared the whole line
I was like the night before I discovered
all these cool these cool tricks
put sounds on what does that mean Oh
sounds let me do I unmute this unmute
sight okay now sound should be on wait
maybe I turn up my volume
okay now sound is on yeah the roofing
Lee game we went down some another
interesting line but if you guys are
curious about that game feel free to
check it out on your own let's move on
let's go and play some more people real
quick I'm really curious how I'm doing
in this Twitter poll I'm sorry for going
outside of Lee chest I'm gonna refresh
the page I'm currently a 30% there's one
hour left if i refresh any change
loading I'm still at 30% whew I need I
need 19 more percent of the votes that's
about 60 more votes I don't think I'll
make it but who knows maybe I'll make it
you guys have Twitter accounts let's
move on little Plotkin let's play little
[ __ ]
and maybe I can crowdsource if people
can give me a little clock in --mode
suggestion I would love to make a little
clock in emotes but I don't know what
symbol would best represent him like
what what what is a Plotkin please give
me ideas I don't think I've ever played
a little talking in simple blitz just
like three three minutes in in one
minute or like variants Jess we're gonna
play a five here simply preparing a for
more distractions I don't know whether
to be thankful or annoyed or distracted
probably all three August Toth really
wants to play you he also sent you a
message oh did I respond to him I
responded once I think I told him that
I'll be free after May first because my
like I can't um I don't say I can't but
it's really hard for me to schedule
things in advance this week because the
my schedule is so chaotic but I do want
to play him like I share the same the
same feelings that he has can I just
wrap this Bishop b5 b-45 let's play d4
Bishop T - it's my h5 it's a weird
position someone is a sub okay hello -
cash money nein nein nein nein nein g4
okay I got my pawns on the wings
let's just play c5 I'll keep pushing
pawns until I can't push pawns anymore
that's supposed to be a secret plan but
maybe I shouldn't have revealed the
secret let's play d4
okay now it's hard to push pawns let's
develop ooh did he have e5 no me denied
me five let's play Bishop e7 and maybe
I'll play like ninety seven and E 5 if
he lets me why are people changing the
color of their font and how do you
change the color of your fonts because
that looks pretty magical the play
picture basics
I just want to remove the night like
this is a type of position where Knights
are better than bishops because the pawn
structure is so fixed okay I'm gonna
play e5 well then I can play g5 my foot
feels so dumb it's hard to play chess
when your foots asleep
wait this is gonna be a time scramble
game did he just fork me that's not nice
but I can take on g4 if you take so I
play h3 I'm not gonna calculate it I'm
just gonna move it's good life
philosophy don't think before you act
now I'm pinning as bishop he's attacking
my rook I could take his nights because
Knights are more valuable than anything
in this position and then I'll play
Bishop c1 and his King is tied down to
his cheap on and then my knight will
come in my queen will come in 9 that 5
is coming 9.5 is it so annoying but I'll
deal with it by 5 I think I can just
take
problem is if I plant my knight on each
floor he'll just trade it off Oh
what to do let's pin him just gonna
delay making difficult decisions
I'm also low on time so I can't really
think much okay I can take the knight
now this is not what I wanted because
now my my bishop is just a dumb piece
but his King is a bit ridiculous let's
play Bishop e7 and King g7 I'm
preventing Queen g5 my rook will come
behind my past pawn and then I'll push
my passed pawn and maybe it will be easy
to play he just wants to win the pawn
may be rook here I don't know I want to
meet him somehow
that's the objective in chess getting
taken Queen h4 what is going on I don't
want to lose a pawn put the bishop there
he's gonna flag me but maybe I can made
him first Bishop here Queen III coming I
smell mates
you can't take on e5 Queen III is made
in one I think he's dead Karina four
wait a minute oh he's not dead that's a
good move let's do this
as king is so ridiculous my bishops a
good piece but how do I made him see
cheese hanging okay i'm gonna win his a
pawn and then promote my icon before he
checkmates me let's do that
ooh i didn't want to do that because he
pushes but i blockade wait what's going
on here this is such a ridiculous
position he's gonna flag me no stop it
draw
oh no he's taking all my pawns with
check and I'm on the trackpad my hands
are sweaty wait no he won my queen takes
a while for the feeling to sink in like
I was so close to me Nathan f60 one bit
saying don't flag I miss anything
do I miss anything really obvious right
around here it just felt so close to
mate
I don't know he defended well I thought
I attacked well my bishop was such a bad
piece it became a a monster on g5 good
game oh that's unfortunate what's still
asleep okay um let's play someone else
we can play Nathan F I've lost track of
how many bits he's given I'm gonna go
ahead and go to stream labs just to
thank everyone who I've forgot about
thinking Oh Nathan F is a good player
over 2000 ok let's play d5 ok so the
most recent follow was from Chester
blitz man Thank You Chester blitz man
thank you
most man knock gamma ray thank you some
fancy potato appreciate all the follows
night see for what is night see for why
not just take my three nights no maybe
this is fret plays d3 so quickly oh this
is too old bullet that's probably why
he's playing quickly
don't lose to Nathan says BG I'm not
gonna lose to him my only loss will be
to little clock in b2 attack he's gonna
play rugby one yeah do stuff with the
bishops 94 will happen this is very
unpleasant for whites c2 is attacked oh
my gosh what just fell on the computer
something fell from the sky
Queen d1 so now I have discoveries but
where's the best discovery take on c2 or
bishop chief no Bishop g4 is a bad move
I shouldn't take all my time here I'm
gonna play Knight b3 I'm just curious
what he's gonna do
I might be preparing rip d2 you up t2
could be a cool move
wait a minute 92 that's a fork it's a
very rare fork you don't see this every
day
92 forking the Queen and the rook now
I'm threatening rip t2 okay now I can
win the a pawn oh let's not pre move
that he's nice c3 if you played a nice
d3 at the right moments I would have pre
moved Queen take a two that would be
very bad now I'll just pawn storm going
with a little Plotkin strategy just
pushing the link on and pretty move this
move Bishop h3
Oh No wait a minute I'm not losing
anything queen g4 is sort of scary but
it doesn't work
okay my take on g7 this could get get
weird
work h1 I guess I can start with and
then just take stuff from g8 I'll win
the Jeep on I'm keeping my time
advantage he wants to take a pawn I'll
let him take the pond I'll give him the
satisfaction of shakedown c7 maybe I
shouldn't have allowed that's maybe had
a stronger move there like Queen d4 but
it should still be okay let's be careful
this King is pretty unsafe it's just
trade Queens he doesn't want the Queen
trade well now I can go after him
somehow
c3 lagging a little bit or he's lagging
a little bit not entirely sure I think
I'm gonna flag him I feel sad for him
says dusky Mountain sad for me or sad
spur for Nathan F good game Nathan that
was a sad ending but that's life
any instructive moments from that game I
guess I can share some opening opening
preparation this is actually a decent
puts variation a lot of people will take
on e4 oh wow thanks for another hundred
bits
Nathan F is a bit leader no he's not the
bit leader bg7 is still a bit leader
okay yeah that was a false false
announcements anyway after Queen take me
for the idea for black is to play d6 and
this is an opening I actually ran into
an attorney inform the white side and
after like eight moves I was losing
material as white from this position so
Luke's wanted to do that I have to take
a call but I want to take a call okay I
might have to end this stream very
shortly but let me just show this
opening preparation and then and then I
might have to end I can't end if I'm
losing the Twitter poll 33 oh so this is
updating live Wow is it updating live if
someone votes does a number change okay
I'm getting distracted what did I want
to say oh yeah d6 and then there's a
really cool trap white will usually play
d4 take take and then Oh more people are
here shout out to a pod nirvana Raymond
always here so okay the idea is after 96
for attacking the pawn and the trap I
have fell into his whites so I played
the most natural looking move Bishop f4
this is the reason why it's a good
plaits trap because a lot of players
will play this as whites without really
knowing too much and then just stumble
into a pretty dirty tactic starting with
box next move like has a very strong
move here in g5 after a bishop g3 black
is already winning a piece with the very
surprising that five
and it's so sad for whites like white
just took material developed and now the
Bishop's getting trapped so so yeah it's
a useful line to know very simple to
play against key for there is a
refutation to this but it's not too
well-known and it would just it would
take some time to go over maybe I'll do
I'll do another stream where all I do is
going over openings but for now do I
really have to go you check my phone
okay well I got a message from from
Andres undressed ah I'm streaming too
late as he's still streaming Wow um let
me let me check something and I'll be
right back but maybe we'll do a stream
reverse the streamer stream did that
make sense I think that made sense yeah
I'll be right back let me just respond
to him wait can I just respond to his
stream I'm so confused
let me go let me go to his chat first
hey address I'm up for playing a match I
just have to make a call real quick and
then I'll be back and ready give give me
five minutes okay so I'm gonna end the
stream I'm gonna raid him and then I'll
be even more famous and then we'll be
back for a match so that should be that
should be a good plan raid thousand bits
if I win okay motivation raid what's his
name
I am oh he has a similar name to me but
he has an underscore I am on dress okay
I'll be right back